How big a role will the Wild Hunt play in
the third season of "The Witcher"? Why is
Yen wearing that familiar mask? And
is that Nibbles? Here are the small
details you missed in the teaser
for season three of "The Witcher."
The Season 3 teaser for "The
Wicher" begins with an ominous line:
"Now, for the first time, I understand real fear."
It's a heavy statement coming from a Witcher, and
especially the eternally stoic Geralt of Rivia.
Though he's a magically-enhanced, superpowered
monster hunter who's lost at least some of
his humanity, Geralt is obviously not entirely
emotionless. It's just that as a general rule,
he likes to play his cards close to his
chest. Even so, fear hasn't ever really
been part of the package. After all, scared
Witchers tend to be dead Witchers. So, what
is the thing that could frighten a guy who fights
gigantic, overpowered abominations for a living?
Though the trailer frames Geralt's fear as
something that's related to a particularly
mighty opponent, it also makes clear that
Ciri and possibly Yennefer are in danger,
as well. He might have his
issues with his former lover,
but Geralt has a close connection to both
women. The fear he admits to may very well
be for their well-being instead of his own.
Here's hoping it turns out to be unfounded.
Apocalypses are often heralded by foreboding
figures. In the world of "The Witcher," the
supposed harbingers of calamity take the
form of mysterious riders from an alternate
dimension. These riders are known as the
"Wild Hunt," and audiences were treated
to a glimpse of them at the end of Season
2. In the final episode, Geralt, Yennefer,
and Ciri come face to face with the leader
of the Wild Hunt in their nightmarish realm.
"Child of the Elder Blood, starry eyed
daughter of chaos. Join the Hunt."
Although the trio of heroes manages to
escape from this plane of existence,
the Wild Hunt craves the blood of Ciri. It's why
they chase after her in the trailer for Season 3.
Their hunt for her is because Ciri has
access to ancient and long-forgotten
magic. The riders of the Wild
Hunt believe her abilities will
save their accursed dimension from
obliteration. Powerful and deadly,
the Wild Hunt will probably be a major focus for
Season 3 of "The Witcher," especially considering
that some of their history was expounded on in
the prequel series "The Witcher: Blood Origin."
Also known as the Wraiths of Morhogg, the Wild
Hunt is led by the elf Eredin. All of the Wild
Hunt members are elves, and they were created as
a means to procure slave labor from other planes
of existence. Their purpose gave rise to their
status as heartless reavers. Hopefully, Geralt is
up to the task when it comes to defending Ciri and
defeating these long-lived extra-planar raiders.
It looks like Geralt is out for
blood in "The Witcher" Season 3,
but at least he's taken the time to prepare his
gear for the adventure. Early in the trailer,
we get a nice action shot of the Witcher pulling
out his steel sword. Eagle-eyed fans may notice
it now features a line of runes running down the
middle and a beautiful green-glowing stone fixed
to the guard. While these weapon enhancements
don't feature in "The Witcher" book series,
avid fans of the video games will
quickly recognize the upgrade system.
Since the first release, runestones have been
fixtures of "The Witcher" video games. However,
In "The Witcher 3: Wild Hunt," developers
CD Projekt Red took it to the next level,
introducing Lesser Runes, Runes, and Greater
Runes. When equipped, runestones offer different
boosts to Geralt's attacks, like a chance to
burn or cause bleeding. They also change the
appearance of the weapons, with colored runes
running down the length of the blades. It looks
like "The Witcher" Season 3 will introduce that
upgrade system in some form to Geralt's weapons.
As Geralt prepares for battle against a shadowy
figure that stands in the hall in front of him,
he drinks one of his many potions to
power up. The Witcher only imbibes
these deadly concoctions when he
absolutely needs to, it's clear
that he's facing a truly dangerous enemy.
But who or what is he actually up against?
The figure is blurry enough to keep
things delightfully mysterious. However,
since they wear dark clothes, it's easy to assume
that they're either a member of the Wild Hunt or
perhaps a Nilfgaardian soldier. However, there's
another powerful force that favors black armor and
is at odds with Geralt: his fellow Witchers. After
Vesemir discovers that Geralt's ward Ciri could be
the key to restoring Witchers to their former
glory, he may want to claim Ciri for himself.
If so, Geralt drawing his sword is a pretty clear
hint that the negotiations aren't going very well.
Another possible identity for the shadowy
figure is none other than the mage Vilgefortz,
who has gained more power within the brotherhood
and may also be setting his sights on Ciri.
Rience returns in Season 3 with a
vengeance. At the end of Season 2,
the assassin is on the verge of
discovering who actually hired him
to pursue Ciri. He returns in the
teaser in a familiar halo of fire,
but that doesn't mean his appearance is more of
the same. The new season could bring clarity to
some of his biggest unanswered questions,
particularly the mystery of who hired him.
"What do you want?" "To meet your employer."
The obvious identity of Rience's employer may be
Emhyr or even Stregobor, but the books reveal him
to be someone else entirely. Though currently an
ally in the show, Rience's master in the novels
is none other than Vilgefortz. The mage who
helped defend Sodden Hill against Nilfgaard,
Vilgefortz has ulterior motives that are
only now starting to come to the surface.
In one of the trailer's blink-or-you'll-miss-it
moments, Yennefer can be seen looking for
Geralt in a dark, torch-lit room. When
she turns around, it's revealed that
she's wearing a mask. Eagle-eyed fans will
remember the mask from a previous episode.
The Season 1 episode "Bottled Appetites" sees
Yennefer set out to restore her fertility,
but the most memorable scene involves her using
magic to conjure up a risqué party in a mansion.
When Geralt and Jaskier find her later on,
she's sitting amid a sea of naked bodies,
watching the erotic events from
behind a lace mask. The mask in
the Season 3 trailer appears to be the
very same one she wore in that episode.
It's unknown at this time as to why Yennefer
puts on a mask and goes running around dark
rooms in Season 3. But the mask is synonymous
with one of Season 1's most memorable episodes,
and it teases another night of
unpredictability next season.
"The Witcher 3: The Wild Hunt" can be described
in one word: massive. The open-world game boasts
close to 200 hours of gameplay. In it you play
as Geralt, trying to find a way to save his
surrogate daughter from the titular Wild Hunt.
With such an expansive landscape, there are many
characters in play. So it's no surprise that
Netflix's "The Witcher" has only scratched the
surface of the franchise's iconic characters.
The new teaser is a window to one character
only briefly featured in the series so far,
Philippa Eilhart. A contemporary of Yennefer's,
Philippa appears in Season 2, mostly to assist
spymaster Dijkstra. But if the source material
is any indication, there's much more in store for
the next appearance of this powerful sorceress.
In the teaser, Jaskier appears on the wrong
end of a sharp-looking ring that resembles
a talon. Philippa's affinity for transforming
into an owl makes her the likely perpetrator,
indicating she will be a player in
Season 3. Like most sorceresses,
she is not all that she appears to be.
Though sometimes affiliated with Dijkstra,
she always has an agenda and uses her powers
as a political tool to achieve her goals.
"Bring me the bard. It's about
time he paid back his benefactor."
Jaskier has a close connection
to Ciri, meaning he may be an
obstacle for vicious Philippa to get
her hands on the young powerhouse.
The mage's lust for power is only one
of her dastardly personality traits.
"The Witcher" Season 2 saw Ciri
live and train in Kaer Morhen,
where she learned how to become a noble
warrior like the witchers of the School
of the Wolf. However, that's nothing
compared to being at the center of a
Continent-wide hunt that brings out the
most formidable killers in the world.
The upcoming season of "The Witcher" is going
to be eventful for Ciri, and that's putting it
mildly. Every mage, monarch, and monster
of the Continent is out to capture her,
and she'll only be able to hide for so long
before she has to face these demons. One of
the storylines will see her become separated
from her guardians, which is evident in the
latest trailer. The Continent is a nasty
world at the best of times, let alone when
the Wild Hunt returns. Chances are good that
she'll encounter trouble at every corner.
Toward the end of the trailer, we see Yennefer,
Geralt, and Ciri wandering around in the dark,
completely separated from each other. The
threat of danger looms large and it's clear
that something is about to go down. Ciri being
on her own indicates that she's going to have
to put her training to good use sooner
rather than later. Geralt and Yennefer
will undoubtedly lend a hand, but Ciri will need
to come into her own if she's going to survive.
In the video game "The Witcher 3: Wild
Hunt," players meet an unusual cat who
sits on a table cleaning itself, stopping
occasionally to stare at Geralt. Cats are
unique in the universe of "The Witcher." They
can soak up magic in a way no one else can,
except maybe a Witcher. Cats hate Witchers,
which is what makes this cat such an anomaly.
Nicknamed Nibbles, his appearance in the
Season 3 trailer comes as a welcome surprise,
given his origin. CD Projekt Red cinematic
artist Kajetan Kapuściński told Kotaku,
"The truth is Nibbles was born as a filmmaking
trick due to a technical necessity that came up."
During a crucial meeting in the video game, the
game designers decided they wanted something to
distract gamers for a short time. The decision to
add a cat was a practical and strategic decision,
but theories started on the internet
that claimed the cat was a shapeshifter.
Alas, Nibbles is just a cat, but he's continued to
show up in random game scenes. Kapuściński said,
"We never expected the few appearances
it makes in 'Wild Hunt' to be noticed.
We've put that cat through a lot
of life-threatening situations
and it's been there as a brave observer of
Geralt's story unfolding before players."
Now that he's officially part of
the Netflix "The Witcher" series,
we hope he becomes just as endearing
as his video game counterpart.